Yeah, there we go. Lovely settings screw
up.
Um, let me get
the stream title or the stream category
fixed
real quick.
Okay, level 18. This is about what we
expected.
Working on continuous. Oh, um, I have
that patch already, man. So, the only
thing that's slightly annoying about it,
um, it's hooked into private client code
at the moment, so I have to like pull it
out and isolate it.
But, I do have a continuous patch.
Um, if I recall, it was I think there
was something with the action sampling.
There were like an epsilon or something
with the
I do remember fixing it though.
But yeah, it's a little bit annoying
because I would basically
like I'd have to offream go like work
through client repo, make sure nothing's
leaking, and just grab that one patch
out.
Yeah,
I will get around to doing that quite
soon. I wanted to port this um this algo
up first. So, I mean here's the uh the
result,
right? We have this looks good.
Why don't we grab this?
Oh, and I also have to update the stream
title.
Um, [ __ ]
Let me just go look at the diff real
quick. I might be able to get it to you.
Hang on. Maybe it's not that bad.
I have a side monitor. One second.
I just have to be very careful because
this is one of our more private
contracts.
I think it's kind of complicated. ated.
So here I can
[ __ ] man I don't remember well enough
honestly
like I'm going to have to actually go
isolated. I know for sure that there's
like around line 7 700 and 750ish.
Um, it's not accounting for multiple
continuous actions
correctly,
but I think there was more to it than
just that.
I'll try if after I finish this, I'll
see if I can um if I can off stream just
like get the thing ported because we
should totally have that working. That's
kind of ridiculous.
I don't know. I've been quite tired the
last couple of days. There's something
of a heat wave here. It might just be
that.
So, this is not a full sweep to be
clear.
Um, I didn't let it sweep any of the
scale params.
This is forced tiny network, forced high
throughput.
I also prevented it from picking like
janky clip coats.
All right.
7 minutes.
Let's see if it drains.
But okay,
our starting point
everything should be
Hello, Tim.
Uh, we have the algorithm.
We have pretty much all our basic setup.
That looks like standard Soo.
No, this is incremental levels.
Incremental levels.
Hello, Elliot. Welcome.
Um
what from the decompiled version?
That game should actually be genuinely
harder to get to be super fast. Like
obviously it can go way faster than the
original,
but that game would be genuinely a lot
harder to make super fast.
What's I mean they're literally train so
they're training their AI on my RL
software that I've spent many thousands
of hours on at great personal cost and
then they're saying that for, you know,
my own good and safety. I'm not allowed
to use it for AI research.
So, [ __ ] them.
Uh,
this is my favorite little bit,
actually.
Where's the uh the notifications?
You can tell there's something wrong
when I have the top comment on um their
announcement post.
And the comment is just [ __ ] you.
You can see the general attitude towards
this thing. A tenth the review of the
views, half the likes.
I honestly the best way to like the best
thing you can do is just not use their
models. You just you're a good good
researcher, don't use their models.
Like don't give them public feedback and
more data.
Don't understand them. They're a bunch
of out of touch losers with a savior
complex.
Don't give them anything. Ignore them.
Build [ __ ] that matters.
Uh what happened here?
Was this just unstable? It was higher
score than this.
I knew a couple of the people that
started well I don't know if were found
on the founding team but joined very
early and yeah they were batshit insane.
This is a variant of Soabon
um that makes you solve a thick set of
increasingly hard levels in order.
The simple version of the new algorithm
is keep the highest episode return
trajectory
and have some ends that have their
starting state set from it.
Okay, so this is actually much better.
It's just that it's unstable.
Yeah, it's very simple, Tim.
Very simple.
Let me see what this gets to before it
sort of crashes.
I said I mean I said two months ago
basically that I switched to Codeex not
because I thought the model was better,
just because I was sick of giving these
[ __ ] money. And lo and behold,
I honestly wouldn't be surprised that
the instability just comes from like
something to do with how we're handling
um or the lack of learning rate healing.
That's level 17 right there.
That to me seems like since it's
crashing right at the end, that would
seem to me like there's probably some
time based, you know, maybe the analing
is not handled right or something,
but I'm happy I've seen the correct
score.
No, advantage doesn't give the right
signal at all. I'll have a blog post on
that.
Okay, good enough as a starting point.
Good enough as a starting point. sub
three minute run we can use to check um
let's start by figuring out what the
heck is here to begin
This is
random crappy logging changes.
off Paul. Nope. Would be very very
different
stays mostly. Well, I mean that's you
can't say it's the same thing except
this stays on Paul. That's like saying,
"Oh, it would be the same except that
one doesn't [ __ ] work at all and this
one works."
Yeah, it would be the same thing except
if this completely wrong idea worked
perfectly then it would be good.
You know
We have to get um we have to get the
code states like as close to each other
as possible because then I can actually
start redesigning it and rewriting it,
you know.
GPU. Uh 49. No, this is my 5090 box. Do
10 pendulums.
I'm working on the core algorithm stuff,
which is the reason that any of that
pendulum stuff all over the timeline
even works.
Pendulum will be a nice end, but I'll
just let one of the many people doing it
PR a version. I know whoever has a
version that's not vibe coded crap, I'd
be happy to take a PR.
This is okay. This is getting deleted.
So that most of this is going as well.
This as well. Okay. So, what we need is
is this thing on?
Hang on. RNN state. RNN reset.
plus one citation.
What?
Oh, are you uh submitting a paper or
something?
You will use amount of samples as hyper.
Uh yeah, that's part of the search
space.
We're trying to delete anything that we
absolutely don't need. I do want to
rewrite this manually, but I don't want
to rewrite crap that's redundant in the
first place. And so the goal is
semi-automatically minimize the diff
manually,
rewrite the shortest possible amount of
lines I need to
Safe log space carry.
The hell is this?
That's very odd.
Yeah. So, it's just [ __ ] with a bunch
of things.
See if we need this.
I have to actually watch it, don't I?
cuz it's a little crashy.
Uh, if this gets the same level of perf,
we're just going to delete that crap.
Okay. The RNN stuff is Oh, no. It's the
same.
Okay.
I'm hoping that I basically just have to
mess with the curriculum file.
new algorithm updates. They work
incredibly well. Which new algorithm
updates? 40 or the state set stuff I've
been doing.
If you use the latest state set, I
wouldn't be surprised if that does just
solve it instantly.
Like the new version is pretty much you
just need a single solve and it will you
need a single lucky reward and you're
good.
Any amount of sparsity this thing can
solve provided that you um you get lucky
once.
So in my mind that this just fully
solves credit assignment, right?
which is
in my mind exploration is a combination
of state coverage and credit assignment.
And this solves about half of the
problem.
Okay, cool.
So, except for this small obnoxious bit
here,
Be very careful with this though. Make
sure we don't break anything in the
process.
Keep in mind this is a 50k parameter
policy.
This thing is tiny.
It's solving a very hard problem.
I know. I haven't been sleeping what,
the last few days.
over ant.
Oh,
no. I'm not
Like the thing is I expect that
[ __ ] So not particularly.
It's also kind of just been really hot.
So the runs in the morning have been
sort of brutal.
I am also down like 8 pounds in the last
month. So that might have something to
do with it.
I like a bagel and a minestron soup with
pasta in the morning,
Modern punch card guy.
No, it's not modern punch card. See,
because there's a one one equivalence
with the punch card code and assembly.
So that's not a good comparison
because you get a very different result.
You'll see that the final code is going
to be shorter and much better than what
we have here.
I want to just get a sense of what the
[ __ ] is uh is different here first.
FFT OBS. H,
that's fun.
All right, let's figure out what's going
on here. So
Well, that's [ __ ] dumb. Holy, look at
that.
Yeah. So, I forgot that I'd already sort
of had an implementation on this.
I might actually want to do the diff
versus
4.0, right?
And here it is
right here.
So, it's basically just all Yeah. Right.
Okay.
So, we do need to just diff it versus
five, I guess, because otherwise
be too much crap.
Repro producing nans. All right, cool.
Thank you.
Yeah, I knew there was some screw stuff
on the continuous actions.
Okay. So, it's like actually
is this 900 lines then?
Not super useful diff
here maybe.
and this was for I believe the implicit
per
Loaded state buffer struck. Stupid
initializations.
Okay, this stuff is actually like the
old code. This is fine.
Yeah, I thought it was less code than
this.
So, we still have to do a little bit of
growing with
We're also going to probably
Do we want an alligator for this?
Allocator, it turns out, is actually a
little bit worse for um
We're not going to stress over that for
now. We're going to do this first.
Let's just fix the obviously stupid
things.
is guard macros? I don't know what the
[ __ ]
there. That's better. Right,
that's minus bunch of code.
That's very fun.
Yeah, I believe Puffer can do that.
It's probably annoyingly expensive to
scale that type of simulation, right?
And let me just check my own usage on
this. Like how is it
Uh
settings.
Yeah, I've only used I haven't gotten
build for anything else.
like how the hell are people using all
of This
this is like using it more than is
advisable
and I'm not running out
on X high.
Like people must be just running [ __ ]
16 terminals 247, right?
You know, I was always wondering why um
how on earth these companies were even
going to get close to breaking even
and then I forgot. People are [ __ ]
I just want to see how much code we
actually have.
If I can at least figure out which chunk
of this is which, I'll be fine.
What are you building, sir? And how do
you I stream on here? This is Puffer Lib
and see the project at puffer.ai. It is
the fastest open- source reinforcement
learning library. You can train tiny
superhuman models in seconds on one GPU.
Um, I am getting ready to manually
rewrite a whole bunch of shitty codeex
code
because we now have a working algorithm.
A pretty big algorithmic breakthrough,
I'd say. Even though it ended up being
quite simple and uh we just need to get
the code to not suck and then I get to
try this in a lot of places. It'll be
fun.
And uh I mean you there is a there's
like a go live thing. You can connect X
to OBS as well.
Oh wait, maybe it is actually.
This is actually all curriculum.
Okay, it is actually all curriculum,
isn't it?
and nothing is shared anymore which is
expected because we no longer need the
multinnomial sample. Right?
Okay.
Date curriculum is 655 lines. I think
that's good enough. I think we can start
with that.
And then we're the thing that I've been
delaying is we're going to have to
actually think about this in a moment,
right?
So, probably after cleanups and stuff.
What? We're at
6K lines.
We've been live what an hour and we
already have a decent starting point.
As long as this works,
I can commit this.
And then we have I was hoping to have
600 lines of code to edit. I think I
have 700 lines of code to edit.
That's not terrible terrible though,
right?
Uh there definitely some performance
things we have to fix as well.
So, I'd imagine it's not going to be
pure code cleanup. We're also going to
have to do
going to be some perf considerations at
the very least.
How are you able to see
this through even though it takes a long
time? Motivation. I'm very very [ __ ]
tired sometimes.
Um, I take breaks, but
I mean, for the most part, I'm doing
something that I genuinely believe has
to exist.
Like, RL's the coolest tech ever. Um,
these shitty [ __ ] language model
companies basically brain drained all
the people out of the field.
And if I don't do it, it's just going to
be forgotten tech.
And this is the I mean this is the one
area of AI that lets us solve imposs
impossible problems on one GPU.
You're never going to get that out of
pretty much any other area of AI.
So
I want awesome sci-fi tech to exist and
somebody has to build the awesome sci-fi
tech.
I don't see anybody else stepping up, so
I got to [ __ ] do it.
Believe me, I'd be very, very happy to
have all this stuff just exist
and go get some rest.
I could very easily spend much more time
than I do just like running and lifting
weights
and
reading and doing whatever the hell
else.
It's all right.
The tech is progressing very quickly at
the very least. That helps. Like
progress is measured in weeks.
I really wouldn't call say I wanting to
do genuine good to be honest with you.
I mean, I care more about the
progression of tech than anything.
Like, yeah, this will help a lot of
people
down the line eventually, I'm sure. But
the um the more immediate goal to me is
just having the ludicrously powerful
tech exist.
I think a lot of the tech we have is
pretty mundane and boring. This is the
cool sci-fi thing to me.
Um,
I especially do want to see this get
into like low-level molecular sim.
I know it's a complex
sort of uh motive. I suppose
I learned in school though, so it's kind
of shitty.
Well, not even really in school. I kind
of had to teach myself most of it.
This is what we have,
right?
Yes.
So
we have the big chunky state buffer
strct
Dude, how is this model so bad that it
can't even figure out how to paste
functions to the bottom of a file?
Whatever, man.
We got about 500 lines of actual logic,
so not too bad.
Um,
I'm trying to think what the best way is
to start with this.
They're in like a really dumb order from
what I can see. I think these are just
random helpers.
Okay. So, this is where we should start.
So, curriculum roll out begin.
We have this on. No wonder this is slow,
right? We have this loop on CPU on the
main thread.
Neil CL
this is zero right now isn't it?
That's just straight redundant.
Get rid of that.
That's not going to be minus much code.
That's minus like 10 lines.
Okay, so this is some janky ass
filtering. Cool. I know what this is
though.
Okay.
It's kind of just bad code is all it is.
It's like doing roughly the right thing.
Okay. This is going to call capture
curriculum checkpoint.
What in the hell is this, man?
That's like crazy jank.
Okay, at least we have the replacement
tail code.
And then
replace full.
That looks more reasonable.
And then some helpers.
Start end.
Oh, wait. That was actually um
minus a little bit of code, huh?
All right. Oh, no. That's about what I
expected. Cool.
I'm going to be I am going to be able to
hand edit this, but the structure is so
[ __ ] weird right now.
I have to at least get it into something
that I can handedit.
like line by line.
This is wrong at way more than the line
by line level. Now
I can look at blocks right now. That's
about the level at which we're at.
tips for getting better at coding in C.
Don't do what you're seeing me do here.
Um, follow my guide.
Implement some simple M's without a
bunch of LM crap.
Like I'm doing it this way because it's
unfortunately it's a bit quicker. It's
probably about twice the speed of me
doing it manually. And um it does allow
me to make more progress even on days
where I'm not fully fully there.
But it's pretty miserable.
And um if you're still learning basics,
you absolutely
don't want to be dealing with this.
Like at least I have the level of
experience to like look through this and
be like, "What the hell?" You know, "Why
is this design this way? Why is this
design that way? No, no, this should be
done this way and that." Like, but if
you don't have that, you're just going
to like tab tab tab tab tab and then end
up with garbage you can't even fix.
That's why this is slow. Okay, that
design [ __ ] sucks.
Oops. Be right back. Let me check one
thing.
All right.
This will take us a while.
Reset deterministic capture ordering.
Okay. Well, this thing is definitely
screwy.
Um,
yeah, this thing is definitely screwy.
Okay, so this is like shitty
this is just shitty initialization
pattern code. All right.
Well, I mean, the cool thing about this
is at least now we have back end of
Auda,
right? Be back. It's back end, right?
Oh, no. Oh, it's Beckham dot.H,
but this can also be
Yeah. No, this is this is CUDA.
Did you buy space? We'll see if anything
went through.
I'm not too worried about it whether I
get it on IPO day or not.
I think I'd rather buy more not on IPO
day.
Break out at wait. running on torch
450k on a six core CPU.
Huh.
I'm kind of surprised it does that on
CPU, but cool.
Yeah, our CUDA native stuff is way
faster. Like breakout with the defaults
is the end of the runs 21 mil SPS on uh
5090.
Okay, this is shitty. But this is like
normal, easy to clean up shitty.
What's this?
Vanilla Ms.
The [ __ ]
How to use LMS to learn anything.
You more than anyone should not be
overly relying on those.
Um,
Yeah, there you go. Right.
This is a short textbook.
This has all your basics.
Um,
I have guides on X as well that point
you to good materials.
I definitely know way more people who
use LLMs way too much and are worse for
it than I know people who are like,
"Wow, they've really learned a bunch
with all these LLMs lately.
So, a couple of these like per block
cleanups I think are going to be
semi-automatic first
because like [ __ ] like this is just why
is it like this? Just don't do it this
way, right? This is not just line edits.
This is structural edits.
Um, we're going to get it to the point
where it's kind of just like stuff like
this. I could line edit. You see this?
This is kind of just normal shitty code
where I can fix this manually pretty
easily.
Um,
we have to actually get it to the point
where it's just this is this level of
bad. It's much worse than this right
now.
You see like this was all redundant
crap.
Well, you could try asking me that
question and see what happens.
I don't know.
Welcome.
How's it going?
Okay, so this thing I have no idea what
the heck
I honestly have no idea whether that
makes sense at all.
Um, I have no idea whether that makes
sense.
Do MIT maker?
No,
I don't think so. No,
I had one random interview. I think that
was something different though.
This is not in a colonel.
Yeah.
mostly to do with Q-learning.
Yeah. So, RL really doesn't work with
the textbook algorithms.
take zero fluff. I'm trying here. I I'm
using definitely too much. I'm using the
models definitely way too much.
But I will I am at the very least. What
you're seeing now is me trying to unfuck
all the code.
I see why it's done it this way, but
this is not an acceptable solution.
So essentially, there's this shared
buffer for the curriculum.
There's a shared buffer for the
curriculum
and it's trying to like determinize the
update order. Hang on.
CLMs don't have their state stored,
right?
Collegebased learning in AI versus
industry working in a company.
Uh, you don't learn much in either, but
in industry you get paid.
Honestly, the best way to learn stuff is
to just have very high motivation and a
bunch of time with which to figure
things out. And ideally,
a few people who you genuinely respect
to steer you in the right direction
occasionally.
or AI companies scaling their what? Like
why would you ask me that? I don't work
on that.
I honestly I work on scaling in the
opposite direction. If anything, I'm the
guy that makes the code super fast for
these small models.
you just do all well just I mean it's
kind of a lot you know like all the
optimizations out there are directed at
super big models there's a whole another
stack that's required for uh much
smaller models
I mean think about it you're interacting
with you're interacting with a
simulation millions millions of times
per second.
Right compass to respect. Yeah, it's a
little tricky.
I was very bad at taking advice when I
was younger, but then I just I kind of
made up for it by doing it for long
enough that I figured it out.
No CS degree, but math.
I mean, I know way more people that are
just they fail because they're terrible
programmers than I know people that fail
because they're bad at math, frankly.
And no, Codeex doesn't fix that.
It's kind of funny like I honestly think
if anything um your intro classes at uni
are the most useful because you'd be
surprised. It's just the amount of
failures that are not failures because
you didn't know some super advanced
thing but failures because people do not
know the absolute basics of anything.
It's mostly just complete basics
failure.
Uh, I don't know. I know stone tow's
reset thing vaguely
if I recall correctly like a lot of the
robotic stuff they rely on having the
space already explored for their resets.
So what I'm doing it's a simple on
policy state uh state thing where you're
not you don't have to have any data to
start with at all. You just have to have
a fast sim
and um it's more go explory. It's kind
of like on Paul RL plus go explore more
than it's similar to the robotic stuff.
Are you able to earn via Puffer what
you'd have earned in top AI labs? Not
yet. Puffer is profitable and it's
growing, but not yet. And that's fine.
I think if I spent a week in SF, I'd go
batshit insane.
Most trial papers having so much math
notation to represent super simple
concepts. I have no idea.
This is what I mean though with like
people tend to fail on the
looking back reset machine.
Um yeah, it's this the algorithm at the
moment the improvement can be described
vaguely as just like store the highest
episode return this the highest return
uh trajectory and then allow some
environments to reset along that
trajectory.
It is a massive improvement. It's very
cool like this algorithm at the very
least you only need to get lucky one
time. You only need the reward once and
it'll learn from that one sample.
Small update via latest DM. Hang on,
Spencer.
I kind of got burnt out yesterday and I
also was installing Starlink in 90°
heat, so I'm doing the uh the cleanup
today. Oops. Let me pull this over here.
Pull this over here.
Huh?
Um,
we handle that just by like merging
multi-discrete spaces, right, Spencer?
with time.
I would doubt it.
I think if anything that like the
current scale like they're just going to
not be served the top model, but they'll
be served a model that's better than the
model you have today.
Uh there are a whole bunch of problems
with advantage that are quite subtle.
That'll be in the blog post. Oo,
I have to admit I've been a little tired
today. So, we have uh or the last few
days even. So, we have the side monitor
content that keeps me sane. One more to
go.
RL's right for time series data. We've
done a little bit of that
professionally.
It's not particularly different from any
other problem.
And I actually have to figure this out
for um
the setup here. Yeah, I got Starlink.
I'm trying to think what we do about
this synchronization thing
because technically
you can technically have to um
replace the tail, right?
Wait,
I think Not.
like works better in remote area. Well,
I was just sick of dealing with [ __ ]
Comcast, so now I have something that'll
just work. Um, I still have the Comcast
one for now, but like I have a backup at
least that I know works.
I'm not in New York City or anything.
It's a suburb. It's fine.
Make it play Snake.
I think this snake end was a little
sketchy for some reason as a 40. I think
the policy might need a couple small
changes.
You could figure it out though. It's
probably not that tough. just hadn't
looked at it.
GPU. Uh, you really should have a GPU.
It'll make your life much easier.
You can rent a um like a 3080 or
whatever off of ass for 10 cents an
hour, though.
Why? Why does everybody assume I know
everything about everything possible
happening in tech? Like, I'm not your
tech news aggregator, my guy.
I try to spend my time as much as
possible not really caring about what
the hell is going on and more so just
like ignore everything, make the thing
work.
Make the actual research advancement.
Squared the name of the single agent. Uh
squared is a single agent test
environment.
It's also such a boring and depressing
question.
I'd way rather know like, hey, does AI
solve disease and aging and like help us
make sci-fi materials and solve problems
we couldn't have possibly imagined
solving a few years ago?
like so much more interesting. thing.
Ray example. Uh we use Rayb for
everything.
I love Rayb. We're their uh their top
sponsor.
So that's not really saying much. They
just don't get anywhere near enough
sponsors.
I don't even think this is on the
company account. I'm pretty sure this is
just me personally, but
yeah,
I am gooey guy supports RIB. That's
cool.
If you have spare money, it really does
help him. Um I think he's like a prof in
Spain.
Guy really does not make much.
And Ray is honestly the best library
I've ever had the privilege of using.
I've learned so much about software from
Ray uh from Rayson.
Like
even his docs are just I like his docks
are perfect.
just like the cheat sheet plus examples
thing is so simple,
but like I remember trying like 10
different ways to write the puffer docks
and then I just did it his way and I
went, "Oh yeah, that's the right way to
do
All right, we're going to see if we can
get this stupid thing to work
cuz it has like massively over
complicated [ __ ] right now. Hey, Jess.
Best buffer,
First time on stream. Algo is complete.
Um, yeah, the algo works. It gets like
18 levels solved. It's pretty cool.
I'm just like slowly trying to unfuck
the code.
Codeex is just really stupid.
I'll go.
Um, it's both, Jess. It's good that the
algorithm ended up being very simple,
but I feel stupid for not having figured
it out faster,
Yeah. So, it just it basically came up
with a completely stupid design where I
had this very nicely this very nicely
isolated parallelism and it just like
added a bunch of [ __ ]
synchronization for essentially no
benefit.
Funny as hell.
Was
I think this probably will simplify a
lot.
I'm trying to think if there's anywhere
else it could have done. Yeah, actually
it has lots of places where it's doing
stupid loops
that are probably very slow.
Uh, there's some way to do this a little
bit better. Oh, yeah. This I was
wondering what the hell this was. So,
good. That's just gone.
We don't need that garbage anymore.
How the [ __ ] do you manage to
wait? How the [ __ ] do you manage to add
more code than you delete doing this?
It's going to surely end up deleting
more. Right.
What are we at? We're at
9:25. Five.
At least we delete this. But it still's
added a lot, hasn't it?
Let's go run it at least real quick.
If it even works,
why are we at 1.2 mil SPS?
Oh, no. Wait. This is what it was
before.
It jumps to 3 mil. Something's wrong.
Yeah. Yeah. Something's definitely
wrong. But that is the speed we had
before.
And we shouldn't have have this
shouldn't be this much worse, right?
Popper for masters reconnect with
people.
Well, yeah. I mean, I'm streaming dev
like most days of the week.
I answer all sorts of puff for lib
related questions here.
There's also the Discord as well. We
have tons of helpful people in there,
some of whom know the uh the low-level
details of Puffer as well.
cuz this is just the tail replacement
thing, right?
It needs to be broken by length.
Yeah. Yeah, that's probably it.
It's probably just not replacing.
I just got sick of answering questions.
Major
We'll see what it comes up with, but I
bet it's the length tie.
That's a very important mechanism.
We'll be patient today, but I think this
is going to be the length tie.
I get this version to match from before,
we'll be good.
And then it'll still be slow, but it
won't have any crappy synchronization in
it anymore, at least.
Yeah, that doesn't look like real
physics at all, does it?
Wait, this doesn't have the um
This does not have the dynamics, does
it?
That doesn't look right to me. Right.
The way it's swung up like that.
That seems really weird that like
there's no bend in it at all. It acts
like one rod.
Okay.
Spin this again.
I mean I would believe that you can do
it with um
I would believe that there could be some
closed form solution to it.
It kind of doesn't matter from our
perspective, right?
They have no mass.
That would be funny.
We're seeing whether or not this um gets
the same level of perf as before. If so,
then the refactored version is good.
Well, no, it's not good. It's at least
the
design of the the design of how we're
collecting segments is no longer
completely stupid. The code still sucks,
but we will see.
It is already up to 13, which was the
previous best
believe.
15. Okay, that was 16.
I think we're good.
And then 17 is fine if it's noisy. Oh,
it it gets 17 anyways. Perfect.
Yeah, that was it. It wasn't breaking
ties.
We'll commit this as stable. Um, I'll be
right back real quick though.
A quick second
plus one
25 lines.
Not what we want to see, but it's also
not the end of the world.
Be able to get those back, I'm sure.
I do feel like there's no oxygen
whatsoever in this room.
Let me put some AC on.
Okay,
now we got to figure out
If we do, I have no idea what the hell
the design of this thing is.
Very odd.
Codeex is very very effective in writing
large amounts of shitty code quickly.
My god,
we're still in the like what the [ __ ]
phase where um the design of it is still
off enough that it's like I don't know
what's going on.
Oh yeah, for anybody new around here, if
you have not starred puffer on GitHub,
what are you doing? Feed the puffer a
star.
We are rounding to 6K now.
Be very nice to hit 6K proper in the
next couple days.
5969.
Non-deterministic global RNG
there
telling all my friends to start. Thank
you very much.
Feed the puffer star. Puffers love
stars. I don't know how many tutorial
items I have to make about puffer fish
eating stars before people get the idea.
You know,
if all my followers started, we'd have
30k plus stars.
Uh, N pendulum is custom and it's just
like a bunch of random people on Twitter
for the most part. Probably just vibe
coding random ends.
We would take a PR for one if it's um,
you know, well written and correct and
not vibe coded slop.
still open edge gym and the tools were
awful. Yeah, so did I. I was at OpenAI
in 2018,
I think, working on the first version of
Neuralarmm.
Nothing was remotely even usable back
then. It's a miracle anything even
worked at all. Um, it's taken years to
get it to like be somewhat decent.
The crazy thing about it is there's not
a single part of the stack that we used
back then that was preserved.
Like every single part had to be redone.
It's not just like we got some things
wrong. It's like systematically every
single possible thing was wrong.
Nuts.
Did this thing just write the most
bloated pot? Like look at this.
eh
like what?
But this is all stuff I can fix. Like
this is all easily fixable. Just padded
crap.
At least this gets the design closer to
correct.
Okay, next thing will be
remove.
That's just sad.
Why is it sad? Because it has to write
two rappers just to use RNG of any sort.
Like
How many dollars were spent on this
model for it to output such awful code?
Like it can accomplish tasks that are
harder than I would expect most um first
year CS students to know, but there are
literally like first year CS students
that write better code than this.
Look, that's inline a
helper function. for rent. Like look,
just plus this for no reason.
It's just stupid.
There you go. Way better.
Well, we should probably think a little
bit more about how curriculum's
integrated.
I don't get it.
It just writes really shitty defensive
code by default.
like it essentially checks every
possible error even if that error is
like clearly not possible in the current
context.
It bas it puts essentially no value on
writing concise code
and like essentially no value on
simplicity at all.
Um,
this is a way worse result. Was anybody
paying attention? Was it higher than
this number before?
[ __ ] I wasn't paying attention during
the training run.
Do you log results? Yeah, of course we
log results,
but we log them down sampled. So, you
know, we would miss it if it spikes.
What is he doing? I am currently
refactoring awful, awful codeex code on
the new algorithm.
The new algorithm is quite good.
I just have to make sure we don't break
it by accident in the process of doing
this.
It's on par right now. So, what
happened?
Did it just get stuck here or did it
crash?
You'll notice I hadn't bothered with the
pendulum. That was just like that thing
blew up on X. I'll take a PR for like a
a good clean version of that end for
sure.
But I'm working on core. I'll go Dev.
The new um the new curriculum learning
method should be a really major
advancement for at least for a good
chunk of different types of
environments. We'll say
Do I just have to run this on a
different seed? Is it just fiddly?
Good model.
Desktop's dead.
200 kPS
on four and five.
The
rod should have mass, not just Yeah,
the rod should have mass. I was confused
cuz like there was one guy that
submitted a non RL thing.
Um, just like a
linear program or whatever. But it looks
weird to me. I I didn't see the actual
code modeling the physics problem in
there. Maybe it was there somewhere.
Annoying. So, we'll figure out what
broke determinism and then we'll figure
out if it still trains well.
After this, I'm going to see if this is
fine. Then I will um I'll just run it on
a different seed.
Outer master way lighter.
Yeah, it looked weird. It basically
looked like it behaved as one pole. Oh,
What's this?
That's weird.
Does it say? Doesn't even have to say
how big they are.
It's an important detail to mention.
Lifesized.
Get another room.
And uh I don't feel like reinstalling
it.
This is not running on Windows either,
by the way. This is sshed into a Linux
box. So,
Really, we shouldn't have possibly
broken anything with that
suffer single-handedly RL pill me.
Thanks so much, horse. Welcome to the
project.
The next update's going to be pretty
cool.
The uh the new algorithm is solving some
pretty crazy problems.
We still have to test it more broadly
and I still have to clean up all the
code, but
making progress
curriculum stuff just pretty basic.
Like that's the correct approach though.
You want minimal reward.
There are only a couple very important
things you need to know about reward
design
and then um you will obviously you sweep
hypers
and anything else is curriculum. Though
I will say
that actually
uh far fewer problems are going to need
curriculum.
Both share the same cash line.
Eh, I doubt that.
I bet it's just a seed.
Jess. We'll just go lasso it and bring
it to your backyard.
LM some engineering.
There's really no engineering required
there. like they just write random dog
[ __ ] and it runs a thousand times slower
than it should and then they're still
bottlenecked by the LLMs.
guy.
You said like what? Four things.
And this is why it's annoying. It's
tough to see if there's a regression.
What comes after puffer? Using puffer to
solve a bunch of problems.
There will probably have to be at least
a little cuda with this update. Not too
much, just a little.
Well, we'll try this again. It's
annoying. That should not have broken
anything. This is what happens though
with the benchmark is unfortunately
going to be fundamentally a little bit
unstable.
Um because it's an exploration
benchmark, right? And that relies on you
getting lucky. And then the timing at
which you get lucky
that can shift quite a bit just from run
to run.
So in some sense I think that this is
not going to end up being a benchmark
env. This is just going to end up being
like a dev env.
We'll use the full Soabon
as the actual benchmark.
drink some water. This is like This is
carbonated water. This doesn't have
anything else in it.
Oh yeah, my stomach is not uh great.
Actually, the seltzer does help.
How the hell is carbonated water toxic?
Pepper, what are you on about?
You all use Joseph as a screen saver.
Wait, is it 10 on YouTube? Cuz then it's
Yeah, it's 10 on Twitch, 12 on YouTube
that I see.
And then however many are on X, it
doesn't tell me
it. Apparently, it does actually help on
Twitch if I bother to set the category.
So, I will try to do that.
I'm here for the CUDA.
Well, it's kind of funny the way that we
have our stuff. So, the entire Puffer
training program uh is compiled under
CUDA.
And the way we do it, we kind of have
our stuff. So, you can just inline CUDA
anywhere you want.
So, it's it's C and C to see all mixed
together.
Puffer mascot takes my eye. Uh, puffer
mascot is going to get an update pretty
soon. I just got the final versions back
from um the artist.
They're pretty good. There are a couple
things I need to fix in post. And then
the main thing I need to figure out is
the uh the lighting that we're going to
use on them because we were just like
rendering them in Unity before and I'm
trying to render them just in Rayb
and it looks a little off without the
lighting.
It's the same puffer fish. Don't worry.
It's not It's the same It's like the
same puffer fish.
Like pretty much we fixed the thing
where like the fins are kind of just
floating and they're not actually
attached to the puffer. Um we smoothed a
little bit of the polygons like on the
face and stuff, but pretty much it's the
same model. And then the thing is it's
getting more animations.
So we have more animations for it now.
Uh, yep. Still curriculum learning
stuff. We are starting to clean up the
code base.
Too much jank there.
But let's focus on
Okay, so this will go away if we can
actually get the RNG fixed cuz this is
like awful.
Yeah. So, I mean, it's essentially now
down to
like these 400 lines.
I think I should do this one last.
Annoying as that is.
So, we're going to make it even worse
before we make it better, I guess.
Lovely
rapper just for RNG.
Absolutely brain dead.
Yeah, it's still state sets. It's a
simpler state set based algorithm. It
works quite well.
No, it's not increasing.
So, this is essentially this RNG change.
I can't tell if this is a perf
regression or just like flipping uh
changing the determinism like changing
the seed essentially. Um
so I'm wrapping it for now. I'm going to
clean up the rest of it and then we'll
just swap the wrapped versions with
literally just a called a rand.
But I want to get to cleaning up the
rest of this stuff first.
goal is for this like this whole version
hover five should be like 500 lines
or the like the update should be like
500 lines
unless I decide to do the um the other
algorithm chunk in Puffer 5 as well then
it'll Maybe like 800.
Um so actually we are intentionally not
restoring the envul
agent will start in the same state but
we are not considering RNG to be part of
the Hey,
if you consider RNG to be part of the
state, the agent can very very easily
learn um RNG nips.
It would almost be funny to tell you the
truth like how that algorithm would look
so stupidly good on something like
Pokemon. It would discover tons of RNG
minips.
It would basically never win a fair
fight. It would just like always be
critting every hit.
good. 17.
We're happy here.
Well,
I'm partially I'm getting to the point
where I can rewrite it by hand. Turns
out a lot of the codeex code was so bad
I have to get it to refactor by blocks
before I can even touch it by hand.
Some of the code is just insane.
Um, the algorithm is capable of solving
17 to 18 levels of increasingly
difficult so in a row where you have to
reset all the way to the beginning if
you fail a single one of
Huffer doesn't have an end link cart
pole,
right?
could just be modified. I think there's
a double pendulum end.
I would just want a clean version that's
actually correct and is not vibe coded
crap.
Zokaban is
I don't even know what the hell that is.
If that's a complexity class, I've never
heard of it.
Soon is very hard though.
I will just interpret that as very Yes,
Soban is very hard.
Um, some of the later levels we're
solving here take tens of millions of
steps of random exploration.
Espace.
I have no idea on that one.
Only vibe code. Hey, you should learn
some C. It's a fun project to learn some
uh some low-level dev in.
Oh,
well, yeah, if you're going to I guess
if you're storing states. Uh,
the funny thing is we have it solved
with a 50,000 parameter network. So,
clearly you can't need that much space.
Let me see if I like this. Append
completed segment.
There's still way too much crap in here,
isn't there?
Now, you can't just check all the code.
The code [ __ ] sucks. If you can't
tell the code [ __ ] sucks, like, it's
because you need to spend more time
writing code.
Well, if you don't learn, you are
missing out by default.
What's wrong with the current state set
that you want to rewrite?
It's shitty codeex code. It's slow and
it's also just awful code.
Like I'm not going to accept this into
the repository in the current state.
How many of these functions should even
exist?
Yeah. Like I'm stuck like asking stupid
stuff like this cuz I'm reading the code
and I have like it's mindbogglingly
stupid. Like I can't figure like I can't
even figure out what the hell the intent
was behind it cuz it's so [ __ ]
like they have these very long function
names, but they don't actually mean
anything, right? It's like
Like I'm back to use I'm back to
basically the stupid tricks I have for
dealing with other people's ass code
bases.
It can produce something that is like
passes the verification, but it does it
in the dumbest way possible.
like it has a pretty high ability
frankly like pass fixed objective.
Um but it will just always do it in the
most [ __ ] way possible
like it's saying life cycle. There's no
[ __ ] concept of a life cycle in this
entire
It's just like [ __ ]
This is the dumb trick, by the way.
It's literally just pasting together all
the functions that are only called once.
You'd be surprised how effective this is
for figuring out what the [ __ ] is going
on.
I mean, the point of this is like it's
basically broken up the logic into a
bunch of chunks that don't make any damn
sense. So, if we just don't have it
broken up into chunks, then I can
actually figure out how it should be
broken up, if at all.
This is basically what I do on the rare
case where I'm like forced to work with
a third party thing and the codebase is
just terrible is I basic I just like
keep pasting [ __ ] together until I can
actually figure out what the [ __ ] is
going Come on.
want to be our physicalist.
I have no idea what the [ __ ] that even
means.
I found a lot of the like philosophy
type conversations that tend to pop up
though in these circles just exceedingly
stupid.
Well, this I can actually start to work
with at least, right?
We have a much smaller number of
functions that are breaking up a more
manageable chunk of logic without
jumping back and forth between each
other constantly.
Let's go look up what the [ __ ] that even
was.
Everything in reality is ultimately
physical. What?
Why is that even remotely [ __ ]
relevant?
Like,
who gives a [ __ ]
I consider myself more of a philistine
than a physicalist. Yes.
okay. So,
we now have
how much code got a little shorter
actually, which is kind of funny.
Let's run this. I'm going to run uh I'm
going to let this training run and go
real quick. I'm going use a restroom.
I'll be right back. Start the puffer.
Uh, cool. It still works. Yay.
Could make any goddamn sense.
that's just completely uninteresting to
me. Yes.
the presupposition of interest is
I don't know why the [ __ ] haven't we
cured diseases and aging and like
I don't know have some cool sci-fi space
travel or whatever.
Why the [ __ ] don't we have do those
things? Huh?
Maybe because we're bullshitting around
asking stupid questions for too long.
How are there still this many [ __ ]
functions?
God damn. This is like
blleh. Exactly. Right. So it it hides
the fact that there's this much crap
because it just splits it up into 20
line functions, but that doesn't make it
better. If anything, that just even more
so obscures what the hell's going on.
So this is the actual code that it
wrote, right?
Why don't you start streaming games?
I stream enough for my work already.
If it is a turn-based video game, it's a
really shitty one. This is not enjoyable
whatsoever.
These two we can probably start to
understand.
I mean seriously like arguably this is
still faster than me doing it manually
including mostly because the research
prototyping in CUDA would have taken so
long. Um but it does take any enjoyment
whatsoever out of my work. This is
[ __ ] awful.
But I don't know. I'm good at just doing
those things anyways.
The thing is I already felt that way
before um before any of these models.
Jazz.
I don't know. I guess it probably let me
do the Cuda stuff before I would have
done it otherwise would be the main
thing.
Like why does it have all those [ __ ]
checks, right?
I don't even know what the [ __ ] it's
trying to do.
It's basically just doing stuff in a
very stupid way that requires a lot of
plumbing.
uh yes, I've been meaning to chat with
them. In fact,
I think I did chat with him like 3 years
ago. Come to think of it.
I'm not happy with the way that this
buffer logic's being handled.
what bio stuff can be done with puffer
to be determined.
Like I don't have to know. I don't have
to be able to answer that to be able to
tell you that it's very very likely we
we we
will be able to do a bunch of cool stuff
just based on like the way that
everybody uses Sim, how slow everybody's
Sims are, how impossible it is to even
try integrating any cool AI stuff.
Like the assumption that stuff is going
to be useful is structural, right?
I had originally envisioned this as
resetting.
right. So, um I'm actually not entirely
sure how I want to have this.
is the intent that you finish the whole
episode.
What would that do?
It biases you towards the tail, doesn't
it?
I guess there are important cases maybe
where
I could see it going either way,
honestly.
How can you set
W but how can I set what up
does seem to hurt PF? I can't really
tell.
Well, I'm trying to think of cases where
one would matter more or not. Right.
This seems like it hurts Perf, but I
don't believe that that's like a
accurate.
Yeah, within two levels it could just be
Noise.
It has not yet been copied into a
rollout buffer.
You must not clear rewards and
terminals.
I don't know if I like that design
either,
I think this whole roll out loop needs
to be
thought through better.
reset, right? And then net and then
Yeah. Okay.
There's also the shitty compute obser
thing, right?
I'm starting to see it. I think the main
thing we actually have to figure out
then is the um
this thing is just like it being dumb,
I'm sure. So, this is going to go away.
The main thing we have to figure out is
the state um or the end of buffer
situation.
Let me go check on a thing and I'll be
right back.
right, I'm going to think about this for
like another 20 minutes and I'm going to
call it. I'm getting tired.
If I could figure this out today, it
would be nice. It's mostly just the way
that we have the end buffer set up. It's
a little janky.
We could just give it reset with a state
arc, I guess, right?
I don't know if I like that answer
either. I don't like the two arg
two argate.
I think we're going to get rid of this
whole call back [ __ ] anyways, All
right.
We'll see if it makes a mess.
I think that's the correct design
though.
The um
the way to make this simpler is to
remove the abstraction that we have a
little bit with the stupid model call
back.
The only reason that that thing is even
still there is because we used to have
the veen file be a C file. Um,
we should just not have it be this way.
It's going to take a few good days of
work to get this cleaned up. I mean,
it's kind of funny in some sense that
the codeex some of the codeex codes way
worse than even I expected it to be.
like completely unsalvageable
and like and so freaking like confused
that um I can't even just like manually
edit. Like I have to actually just be
like, "What even the hell is this?"
It'll be way better when I finish it,
but such a pain.
Yeah, it was crit. Well, it wasn't for
initially faster implementation as much.
It was like I was experimenting with a
whole bunch of stuff.
yeah, I'm going to finish this and end
stream. And uh one mildly amusing update
from the side monitor here.
Yeah, I think what's going to happen is
that the net call back is going to get
completely deleted. It's going to get
wrapped into this thing. We're going to
find some way to tighten up the
vectorzation loop.
Um,
and or split it up a little bit
differently.
Well, this is progress.
This was uh
How many of you maxed?
things going so far. They're going, but
they're irritating, I would say.
Let's see if it totally breaks this.
It's like Codex is like that one
engineer who writes just such [ __ ] code
that you can't fire the guy without just
cancelling all the projects he's on.
So
essentially now I have to bit by bit
like get the structure of this crap crap
code into something reasonable to the
point that I can edit myself then do
even more work manually like making it
not total crap
and ultimately I think it'll be all
right and we'll be able to do it only
adding maybe 500 lines to the codebase.
Total pain in the ass though.
And number of 99s. One, two, three,
four.
Um, I think mostly it's not even you
like most of the stuff these days is
still just like scripting.
I do not bought the game. It's my
favorite game. If anything, I'd be way
more interested in uh chucking my stuff
on to model bot behavior and get them
all banned.
They do really just destroy the whole
economy, which is the thing that makes
the game work.
How long have I been playing that
account?
Oh, I've been playing this one uh let me
see
I really only decided recently to do
some skilling. I mostly just did PVM,
but needed some side monitor content for
the last um few engineering grinds
and also to prevent this [ __ ] from
driving me nuts.
Uh, why did it suddenly just get way
faster?
schedule free amuse.
So schedule three would be really nice
for RL because it's very annoying that
we get completely different results when
we run our experiments for longer or
shorter.
I have no idea what it made slow. I knew
that there was some dumb [ __ ] in
there that was slow. Um,
it'll be interesting actually now to
figure out if we can do even better.
But that should be it. I've pushed it
now to 5.0 I know simple CL
we'll continue this probably Monday
maybe tomorrow but probably Monday
able to take a checkpoint
uh it's not just about being able to
take a checkpoint for a train model
let's say I tune the hyperparameters for
a model and I get like you know some
good hyperparameters for a 100 million
parameter run if I go and run the same
thing for a billion steps it'll often
just completely fail. That's really bad.
So, not having the LR nailing would be
very nice.
Okay. Um I think we're going to call it
there. That's at least an initial bit of
progress on the refactor.
A little bit of manual stuff. Mostly
still just fighting dumb model, but it
happens.
I I have come up with a few architecture
changes I think for the
like the way that we do our VE and 50
that should help. We'll see how that
goes. Um, thank you everybody for tuning
in. If you're interested in my work and
you want to support us for absolutely
free, puffer.ai,
star the puffer on GitHub. It says 6K
here, but I'm waiting to celebrate until
it actually hits it without rounding.
So, 30 more stars to go.
And other than that, join us on Discord
if you want to get involved or follow on
X for more reinforcement learning
content. Lots of stuff on here. Lots of
people getting into RL.
It's fun.
Enjoy your